this week on the climate show what
sounds like a heresy we don't need to
save honeybees in fact there may be too
many of them
[Music]
hello and welcome to the climate show
now it's World b day this weekend but
I'll be finding out why beehives like
these could actually be harming nature
also on the program
the public transport subscription that
Germany hopes will help kick the
country's car addiction
as wildfires rage an election is being
held in Canada's oil-rich patch that
could influence National Climate policy
and we show you the science behind the
search for more climate-friendly sheep
save the bees has become a Clarion call
in recent years leading to many people
getting colonies themselves but now
scientists are saying all those hives
may be doing more harm than good
flourishing nature needs abundant bees
they are essential for the reproduction
of wildflowers and the production of
many crops so news that they might be in
Peril triggered a 21st century boom in
beekeepers
what is it not to like about bees these
are really really fascinating index
um they communicate in a very
complicated way that Society is really
structured I started beekeeping because
I had a mild itch the more I learned
about these the more I wanted to learn
about bees they're fantastic my Queens
the one on the left hand side is called
little Liz and the one on the right hand
side is called Megan and they both get
on very well
but be careful what you wish for recent
studies suggest our taste for the
honeybee has gone too far in urban areas
where it's very built up and there's not
a lot of forage for bees there just
simply isn't enough food out there for
them and keeping one species of
pollinator does not necessarily mean
you're going to help the rest of them
here at Kew Gardens they have a greater
variety of wild bees than almost any
other Garden in Britain I'll take you
around here and we'll have a look at
this comfrey or symphytum which is uh
usually buzzing with wild bees at this
time of day beautiful color I always
gather that bees like blue is that just
uh no absolutely there is there is
scientific evidence in fact you can see
a bombus terrestris right here bumblebee
I believe sorry a bumblebee that's right
and then I've seen some hairy footed
flower bees and their studies looking
across London have seen those wild
populations Wilt as honeybee colonies
blossomed a similar trend has been seen
Nationwide it's all about the density of
hives so our work suggested that about
seven hives per square kilometer was
about as much as London could tolerate
considering the green space that we've
got available we've got quite a lot of
Green Space yeah in London in some
locations in London there are more than
50 hives per square kilometer and in one
particular location there are 400 hives
in a square kilometer and they all need
feeding so that is thousands of mouths
in an empty Supermarket absolutely in
fact each Hive is between 20 and 50 000
hungry mouths pollination is the act of
taking the pollen between the male and
female parts of different flowers
allowing seeds to form
vital for crops like rapeseed or soy and
fruits like strawberries or apples
hundreds of different bee species do the
job we've got over a hundred species
that we've recognized or described here
in Kew Gardens to give you an idea of
the kind of bee diversity that you get
is your favorite
I probably do actually I think it's the
hairy footed flower bee we actually saw
one of these flying about in the simple
item so hairy footed flabbies come in
two forms so that's the female with
black body and yellow hairy legs or
hairy feet and that's the male there and
they're often some of the earliest bees
you get in the garden other pollinating
insects beside wild bees can suffer from
competition with honeybees beetles wasps
moths butterflies and flies like this
aptly named bee fly
I think I want to see one of these wild
bees for real so the only way to do it
is to catch one and my hunting trainer
is Ellen Baker who's a PhD student here
Ellen how am I going to do this so we've
come to one of the flowers that we've
got a lot of the Bumblebees on we've got
one of our native species bombus
pascorum and we're going to go for a
nice downward swipe and then put the net
on the floor and we're going to put her
in a little pot so we can have a closer
look they are kind of like a Ginger
Ginger color did we get it we got it and
are these the kind of wild pollinators
that we need to encourage exactly so
wild bees like this can really do with
our support in our Gardens at home but
also in terms of like bigger National
decisions that we make and how do we
encourage them it's all about basically
giving them space to live and stuff to
eat so by and large that means
conserving areas that we have and
planting more flowers in places where
there's not enough simple as that
habitat habit a habitat it really really
is to be honest I mean bees have been
doing like really well for a long time
without our help and now as the
landscape's changing they need our help
more and more don't want to create an
even more angry baby probably ought to
Let It Go
so have beekeepers got the message
gently pulling this out so that we don't
disturb them
it always amazes me how tolerant they
are to this kind of disturbance
this honey Harbor is just beside the
city of London but all bar one of these
hives are now being moved out of town to
make room for more wild pollinators in
essence why are you deciding to scale
back the amount of hives here
well we can actually see that there are
sufficient honeybees here some would say
that the concentration that we see
London is the Europe's most densely
populated city for honeybees possibly
the world we've been hijacked by the
save the bees
motto which has been interpreted as
meaning honeybees
well guess what the honeybee is in great
fatal the UN Hive data for honeybees
globally shows you that they're an
all-time high
so what we need to do is impact see the
impact that these honeybees with their
proliferation especially in places like
London is having on other pollinators
and in particular of a wild bees
so save the plants that pollinators need
less catchy as a slogan more true to the
science
now as many workers here grapple with
the cost of living crisis including
steep rises in the cost of commuting one
scheme in Germany is attracting some
envious glances as our Europe
correspondent Siobhan Robbins reports
is a green transport Revolution coming
down the tracks in Germany a season
ticket costs for British commuters saw
Germans can now travel the whole country
for just over 40 pounds a month we had a
real complicated Terror and ticket
system in Germany and now we have
introduced just one ticket valid for the
whole month for only 49 euros and
there's no risk you can
get away get rid of it after a month if
you if you would like to it's very
simple and that's like a ticket
revolution in Germany
it's valid for unlimited Journeys on the
country's trains trams buses Subways and
even some ferries only high-speed
services are excluded
and it's popular to date 7 million have
been sold the advantages are that I can
use it all in Germany
and I don't have the different
constructions if I go to Hamburg for
example I have I don't have to look if I
need a ticket or not and which are the
conditions of this ticket in Hamburg for
example so I have one ticket for Germany
and everywhere it's okay
stick finishes shown by a man
not Jewish
is foreign
[Music]
the new ticket is based on a nine Euro
pilot pass last summer designed to help
Germans with the cost of living crisis
that cut car Journeys by 10
preventing 1.8 million tons of carbon
dioxide emissions the ticket is cheaper
than than going to the gas station going
for a ride and that's why we we think it
will it will be a measure successful
measure for fighting the climate change
but campaigners say more needs to be
done to curb the country's car culture
while it is offering this 49 Euro ticket
on the other hand it's still building
more highways actually in transport
policy Germany's
far far away from being green
we're a car dependent society and this
needs to change
critics also point to the 3 billion Euro
cost and say it does nothing to improve
public transport in rural areas
but the price might just be justified if
it breaks Germany's Autobahn addiction
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Berlin
now across the Atlantic a Canadian
Provincial election isn't normally
something that would gather much
International attention but as voters go
to the polls in Alberta at the end of
this month plenty of eyes are trained
there
it's the Western province that hosts
Canada's enormous oil sands industry one
of the most carbon intensive ways to
produce the fuel
despite its squeaky clean Global image
Canada actually has a poor track record
on climate action with its average
emissions per person sitting much higher
than most of its Western piers and
nearly three times that of the average
British person that's why Justin Trudeau
has been announcing a tranche of new
plans to bring down the country's
emissions including targeting the oil
sector
but to do much of what he wants he needs
a friendly government on side in Alberta
a place where he's enormously unpopular
and where the current conservative
Premier Danielle Smith has threatened to
block anything that damages the oil and
gas industry
that's despite the province being
increasingly exposed to the dangers of
climate change with a may heat wave
smashing records in the last few weeks
and starting intense wildfires that
ironically have halted oil production in
many areas and have forced tens of
thousands from their homes
well to talk us through this I'm joined
by calgary-based environment journalist
Drew Anderson Drew thanks for joining us
you know as you get closer to this
election what's actually happening on
the ground in Alberta well it's an
interesting time to have an election
that's for sure the province especially
in the north has been hit with massive
wildfires um so that's sort of this you
know almost apocalyptic background to to
this election that's happening right now
there's not actually a lot of talk about
climate change in the province right now
certainly from the politicians
um but scientists have directly linked
these sort of increased incidences to
climate change perhaps Why move back a
bit I mean it's an interesting place
you've got these wildfires possibly Into
Climate Change you've got a massively
carbon intensive oil resource there
you've got an election going on and yet
as you say climate change is not a big
part in this I mean how come explain a
bit about the politics and the society
there Alberta is a unique place I mean
this is a place where people care about
at the environment but it is also a
place where you know hundred thousand
people work in the oil patch the economy
is directly linked to it the provincial
you know fortunes the budget sinks and
swims on the price of a barrel of oil
um it is enmeshed in this Society so
it's a really complicated conversation
you can't really win an election in this
place while demonizing the oil and gas
industry it's it's it's a losing
proposition but there is also this big
conversation that we need to have about
climate change and its impacts like
these fires that are burning
give me the Potted profile of the two
main candidates in this election and and
how they relate to this issue we've got
um you know the UCP government the
United conservative party
um they were in power before the
election was called
um they are to the right
um and led by a fairly new arrival in
terms of the Premiership in Daniel Smith
who has been buffeted by
um controversy since she assumed the
Helm of the party about seven months ago
is she a bit trumpian or is that a sort
of lazy stereotype
um it might be a lazy stereotype but
it's not necessarily inaccurate
um that is certainly an accusation
that's been leveled I'm guessing pretty
pro unashamedly pro the oil industry
would that be right yeah absolutely yeah
and and is setting herself up for fights
with the federal government over
environmental policies talk me through
that because you know there is a lot of
power in the provinces in Canada so what
what is it she might wish to block just
in the very our future we've got a
government that's pushing aggressively
towards its Net Zero by 2050 targets a
nationalist you know a national
government do you mean yeah nationally
yep um you know they want a net net zero
electricity grid by 2035. a lot not to
like if you are in effect a Petro
Province um tell me about the uh the
more left-wing uh uh opponent yeah so
it's interesting that we've got a Social
Democratic party sort of on the left
um the new Democratic party led by
Rachel notley but they've actually
positioned themselves pretty squarely in
the center of the spectrum and again you
can't win an election while demonizing
oil and gas here so they are
pro-industry but they take a more
temperate approach uh when they were in
power between 2015 and 2019 they brought
in a fairly ambitious climate plan to
tackle emissions in this province while
working with industry and they've been
sort of cautious in this election not to
talk about it
um so we do have the UCP on the right
who is you know trumpeting uh fighting
with the federal government protecting
oil and gas jobs and then we've got the
NDP sort of in the center hoping not to
really talk about it but certainly
supportive broadly of these policies
from the federal government
if the United conservative party the
more right-wing candidate is uh elected
re-elected what impact could that have
on on National policy does it
destabilize things nationally for Canada
just briefly absolutely
um if you've got a premier that is you
know determined to fight uh and to fight
hard on all of those policies that are
coming down that's going to destabilize
And Delay these conversations in this
process
um and they have proven themselves
willing to go as far as the Supreme
Court of Canada to try and block these
sorts of things a really interesting
microcosm of the pain of transitioning
away from a world Economy based on oil
and gas sir Drew thank you very much
indeed for your time
it is interesting what's happening there
is a little bit like the pain that's
being felt in parts of our economy that
are dependent on North Sea oil and gas
as that winds down
well after the break we'll be looking at
how sheep could be bred to become more
climate friendly and also we'll be
catching up with Sasha Dench as she
looks at how a big renewable energy
project in Morocco could affect
migratory Birds
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the climate show now one
of the toughest nuts to crack when it
comes to global warming is the methane a
really powerful greenhouse gas that
comes out of cows and sheep both ends as
a matter of fact so finding a breed that
emitted less of that would be a prize
really to be wished for and our Science
and Technology editor Tom Clark has been
looking at some promising developments
for Rob Hodgkin's flock it must feel a
bit like being abducted by aliens
arriving in their Hertfordshire Barn to
find it home to a space-aged trailer
containing sheep-shaped Chambers into
which each is sealed in the name of
planetary science
eight two one
20.9
oxygen in fact this is an experiment to
study how much methane each sheet
produces because when it comes to Global
Climate ruminance cud chewing animals
are a major source of this greenhouse
gas
there are 3.6 billion domesticated cows
sheep and goats on the planet their
digestive systems create nearly a third
of human-linked methane emissions and
while short-lived methane has about 28
times more global warming potential than
carbon dioxide
yeah
a government grant has helped bring this
equipment from New Zealand where the
methane emissions from this breed of
sheep has been extensively studied this
is the first time it's been used in the
UK
each year British sheep belch out
methane equivalent to about 5 million
tons of Planet warming carbon dioxide
purpose of this experiment is to see if
it's possible to single out the green
sheep of the family to breed low carbon
flocks of the future
technicians carefully monitor the
animals for signs of distress they're
released if they aren't comfortable with
their confinement but most relaxed
enough to do what comes naturally it's a
bit of an indelicate question but when
you're measuring methane is that what's
cheaper farting out or burping out
virtually what they're burping out so
it's really related to their digestive
system
one way to reduce emissions from farm
animals is to eat less meat of course
but for this farmer it's an opportunity
to reduce the carbon hoof print of his
flock I firmly believe in 10 to 15 years
time there is going to be a market
demand for loam methane sheep or low
methane animals or carbon sequester in
farms in general how much do you think
you might be able to reduce methane I'm
just interested in in the sort of 10 to
15 reduction because at 10 to 15
reduction potentially will give me an
advantage of a Marketplace when it comes
to try and sell meat to Tesco's
Sainsbury's we've got something
different to offer
if low carbon lamb cutlets don't command
a premium Rob hopes he might be able to
sell carbon credits to companies wanting
to offset their own emissions
underwritten by his lower methane sheep
after 50 minutes of methane monitoring
the Sheep are released to a breath of
fresh air
and a chance to ruminate on their ordeal
Tom Clark Sky News Hertfordshire
extraordinary images there in the name
of science I never thought I'd see a
sheep in what looks like a tumble dryer
now in previous months we've been
following the conservationist and
Explorer Sasha Dench as she tracks the
migration of Ospreys from Guinea in West
Africa back to Scotland she's recently
been in Morocco where concerns have been
raised about a huge new renewable energy
project that some experts say could harm
migratory Birds
so this is the Gelman region where there
are plans to build
and ship the power back to the UK you
can see why it is a prime spot for both
solar power and wind energy it blows
windy all through the night there's a
vast area of desert but for some reason
this has been a black spot for
electrocution of birds on Powerline
pylons
foreign
[Music]
some of the most important areas where
we need to be most mindful of this
potential Collision the Collision risk
for Birds is Within These migratory
flyaways and Morocco and southern Spain
are is an area where a lot of migratory
birds get funneled to Once birds have
migrated across the high Atlas they're
on the lookout for patches of green
where there might be food and there are
plenty in small patches if you build
power lines near them you're bound to
have an impact
things like land use disease and hunting
broadly if if we build out
this Microsoft expansion of wind energy
and solar energy and and power lines
needed to connect them all up then there
is a risk that will end up exacerbating
those those
declines
the good news is there are ways of
planning to try and avoid collisions
with the main migration route and also
you can build power lines with birds in
mind so the chance of electrocution is
very small the pylons might even be
helpful as places to put in a desert
region where there are no trees
the company behind the latest project
being built here told Sky News they've
conducted surveys that revealed no
significant passage of migratory soaring
Birds and the final design of their
pylons and power lines is still under
assessment
and I'll be catching up with Sasha again
in coming weeks as she nears the end of
her journey but just a reminder you can
catch up with all the environmental news
on the Sky News website or app or by
scanning the QR code on your screen
right now and that's it for now we'll be
back same time next week with a special
program all about carbon capture can we
stop it getting from polluting
Industries into the atmosphere and can
we pull it down from the atmosphere and
lock it away for good see you then
foreign